un écosystème c'est un petit peu comme
un château de cartes quand on enlève ou
qu'on ajoute une espèce les conséquences
sur l'équilibré du milieu se font tout
de suite sentir exemple de la loutre de
mer illustre bien cette situation
presque complètement éradiquée à cause
de sa fourrure elle est de retour sur
les côtes de la colombie-britannique
pour le bonheur ou le malheur de
certains
[Musique]
capricieuse mais son charismatique
regarder leurs visages
à l'aquarium de vancouver les loutres de
mer font un tabac
les gens qui regardent
les loutres à la cua rien par exemple y
mettre que c'est mignon il bosse bien
qu'il tient pas tant ce
carnivore elles sont un élément
important de leur écosystème
et l'écosystème sera complètement
différent qu'il y ait des loutres de mer
ou quoi
mais leur présence ne fait pas que des
heureux
honnêtement on devrait limiter leur
population
[Musique]
tofino sur la côte du pacifique
linda n'ait causé sa collègue partent en
mer pour une mission bien spéciale
compter les loutres de mer
sauf en demie nous faisons ce travail
chaque année nous évaluons la taille de
la population sa répartition et
l'augmentation de sa population
si les loutres de mer reste toujours
dans le même secteur nous avons donc une
bonne idée de la répartition des animaux
cela nous permet de voir à quel point la
population a augmenté
selon les estimations des biologistes il
y a aujourd'hui environ 8000 loutres de
mer au large de la colombie britannique
il y avait tant il y avait environ 3000
litres
on a vu des taux de croissance de la
population très élevé de l'ordre de plus
de 18 % par année mais dans l'ensemble
la population augmente d'environ 5 6%
par année en ce moment
l'histoire de la loutre de maire en est
une de rebondissements
jadis présentes le long des côtes du
pacifique du japon à l'alaska de la
colombie britannique jusqu'au mexique la
loutre de mer a été lourdement chasser
dès l'arrivée des européens à la fin du
xviiie siècle
deux raisons les gens sont venus tôt la
côte c'est une fois la foire qui valait
tellement d'argent en asie c'est
tellement aimé et nook sérieuse que tout
le monde en voulait
ils ont chassé au point que il restait
plus rien enfin la dernière goutte qui
était tué était tiré dessus c'était en
la loutre demers a presque complètement
était décimé des côtes de l'amérique du
nord seuls quelques spécimens se sont
réfugiés dans des baies très isolée de
l'alaska est resté quelques heures en
alaska
dans les îles a le sien où c'était très
très difficile pour les gens d'aller
aussi dans le golfe d'alaska par exemple
une souris qui reste encore quelques-uns
durant les années 60 les états unis
procède à des essais nucléaires en
alaska notamment à l'île d'amchitka
l'endroit compte quelques l'autre
vous allez tuer tous les animaux autour
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour le
sauver
le transporter 80 de la avon cobourne
sont exposés les reporte ainsi entre
1968 et 1972 il y a eu trois essais de
réintroduction de loutres au large de
l'île de vancouver en tout 89 animaux
ont été réintroduits et depuis cette
moment là la profession a commencé à
reprendre au début tout doux tout doux
tout doux mais dans les dernières vingt
ans ça monte avec une vitesse alors on
les voit pas partout encore mais
aujourd'hui on sait où les trouver
[Musique]
nous n'avions pas à gérer cette
population pas à créer de programmes de
reproduction une fois relâchée dans un
habitat de qualité tout s'est fait
naturellement
les loutres ont été réintroduites dans
un écosystème - était absente depuis 200
ans il y avait donc des tonnes de
nourriture
normalement les populations de l'autre
s'autorégule en fonction de l'offre de
nourriture donc imaginer ce qui se
produit lorsque vous introduisez 89
l'autre et que vous leur offrez cet
immense buffet qui s'est construit pour
elle depuis des centaines d'années
la loutre de mer est considéré comme un
prédateur important sa présence est
essentielle dans l'environnement
les loutres de mer font partie des rares
animaux avoir été décimé puis
réintroduit
ça résulte donc une occasion chercheurs
de comprendre les relations entre les
prédateurs et leurs 3 ainsi que la
cascade d'effets de leur présence dans
un nouvel environnement
cela veut dire que l'écosystème sera
complètement différent qu'il y ait des
l'autre de mer ou possède
par exemple les loutres mange beaucoup
d'oursins les oursins e s'attaque au
varech une algue sous marine
la réintroduction de la loutre ainsi
limiter les populations d'ours 1 et donc
favoriser le développement de forêt de
varech ses forêts sous marine permet aux
poissons de se protéger et de se
reproduire cela permet aussi de réduire
la force des vagues et des études
démontrent que les forêts de varech sont
d'importants puits de carbone
au cours de la dernière décennie les
scientifiques ont remarqué que les
l'autre peuvent exercer le même effet de
cascade dans les habitats de zostères
ses longues herbes aquatiques
[Musique]
les loutres mangent les crabes cela
n'enlève l'impression de prédation sur
les escargots et les limaces ces
invertébrés e nettoie les épiphytes ce
sont des micro algues qui poussent au
dessus des austères appartenait toyal
favorise la photosynthèse des aigues
marines
il y a six fois plus de biomasse de
zostères marine dans les zones où il ya
des l'autre de mer que dans les zones où
il n'y en a pas
mais la réussite de la réintroduction de
la loutre de mer et son impact sur
l'écosystème ne font pas que des heureux
cailleux kate est un petit village
côtier des premières nations de l'île de
vancouver
si tout près d'ici il y à 50 ans que les
premières loutre ont été réintroduits
il n'y avait pas de l'autre ici quand
j'étais jeune y'avait pas d'appareil
radio ni d'autres trucs comme ça ici à
la fin des années 60 quand ils ont
introduit les loutres nous ne savions
même pas ce qui se passait jusqu'à ce
que ça soit fait nous n'étions que des
indiennes il ne se souciait guère de
nous
[Musique]
aujourd'hui francis gillett participe
avec une petite équipe au décompte des
populations de l'autre
à l'aide d'un drone ils peuvent bien
évaluer le nombre d'animaux dans le
secteur
ces images démontrent que la population
de l'autre ici est en excellente santé
nous avons compté plus de 6 ans l'autre
en une semaine c'est presque en moyenne
une centaine par jour
nous voulons suivre la population pour
ultime en développer un plan pour
contrôler leur nombre
la loutre de mer peut consommer
l'équivalent du tiers de sa masse
corporel par jour soit environ 15 kg de
nourriture
oursins crâne palourdes ou autres
mollusques il est évident que l'animal
un impact son abondance de ressources
at
il tout juste là bas nous marchions une
trentaine de mètres sur la plage pour
aller chercher des palourdes pour manger
tout était là
mon grand-père récolter les fruits de
mer pour nous tous il y en avait
toujours assez gueule pas de problème il
y en avait pour tout le monde et
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus rien
je suis probablement l'une des dernières
générations à avoir vu certains des
fruits de mer que nous avions ici et
j'ai la trentaine donc lhi l'autre on y
tenait pas important sur notre
nourriture traditionnelle chez les
cheminots foot
honnêtement on devrait limiter leur
population de cette façon il pourrait
aussi avoir un retour des autres espèces
et donc un meilleur équilibre
pourquoi ne pas en déplacer encore une
fois sinon on fait quoi au juste on leur
tire dessus c'est la moins pire des
choses que je puisse dire leur sujet
devant la caméra
[Musique]
la loutre a été chassée éradiquer
réintroduite et maintenant sa population
augmente rapidement elle fait désormais
partie du paysage comme avant l'arrivée
des européens il ya 200 ans
c'est plus le système qu'on a connus
qu'on a pensé que tu es normal
par exemple
ce qu'est vraiment mal de s'adapter
ce sont de petits animaux très résilient
ces femelles avec leurs petits qui
flotte sur la mer elles sont là 24
heures sur 24 tous les jours dans toutes
les conditions grosse bague vent froid
ou tempête
et
elles sont un exemple parfait qui prouve
que si nous voulons réintroduire des
animaux et les protéger ne pouvons faire
ses choix de société maintenant il faut
faire face à nos propres besoins et là
c'est la complexité du prochain chapitre
on
[Musique]